E aí
[Música]
e
as pesquisas feitas em
[Música]
E aí
a
parte das coisas que eu sonhei se
realizar um tão rápido isso só poderia
significar que o meu fim estava próximo
até hoje sempre tive um dia muito bom
para ver se um agradecimento cheio de
carinho ou quando eu vejo realizando
algo grandioso eu falo pronto eu já
posso morrer agora que as pessoas
normalmente se incomodam e responde aí
para mim credo que eu vou e me pedem
para bater na madeira e afastar esse
assunto
e como vocês podem ver a morte ainda não
vê pelo menos não na sua forma
convencional
É eu sei que as ideia pode soar morna
mas quanto mais o tempo passa mais eu
acredito que da mesma forma que não
existe Triunfo sem perda não há vida sem
a ideia de morte
é mas antes de aprofundar todo esse
pensamento eu quero contar uma história
de amor e a história sobre esse meu
primeiro namorado de verdade
e a gente se conheceu na faculdade eu
tinha mais ou menos uns 19 anos e apesar
da gente não ser um casal muito Óbvio
mandarmos muito conectados a gente viveu
o nosso relacionamento
intensamente cheio de declarações
gargalhadas viagens e claro com muitas
lágrimas também
e nós terminamos depois de quatro anos
porque a gente entendeu estávamos em
fases diferentes da vida e que a gente
queria mesmo ficar junto era melhor a
gente separar agora para tentar de novo
mas para sempre
passou mais ou menos 11 meses sem a
gente tem nenhum contato e uma notícia
segunda-feira ele me ligou
e a gente ficou umas três horas
conversando e na semana seguinte a gente
trocou mensagens
textos e vídeos sobre o amor genuíno
como me inscrever no sábado e no domingo
de manhã logo que eu acordei eu recebi a
notícia de que ele havia falecido
naquela madrugada em um acidente de
carro
isso aconteceu há exatamente sete dias e
na antroposofia a ciência que estuda a
natureza O Homem Universo Esse é o tempo
de 1 cm o tempo para grandes mudanças e
fechamento de ciclo aconteça
é independente da variabilidade numérica
que uma teoria como essa possa ter essa
história é muito responsável pela minha
forma de enxergar a vida e de tomar
grande parte das minhas decisões
e essa foi a primeira vez que eu vi a
morte e apesar de nunca ter sido
ensinada a lidar com a finitude da vida
eu me lembro que no meio daquele velório
eu encontrei um pouco de calma
reconhecer aqui de todas as pessoas que
estavam ali eu fui aqui mais Aproveitei
ele enquanto estava vivo eu se Lembrei
no dia que eu saí correndo do aeroporto
EA jejum intercâmbio para ficar com ele
e eu me lembrei quando a minha mãe pediu
que eu aguardasse o meu orgulho e
perdoar uma traição
e por mais que a morte seja tão
conhecida pela sua concretude não
existem números e estatísticas oficiais
que registrem as pequenas mortes que nós
temos envios a morte de que forma a
morte do que planejamos
e a morte no que sentimos e
nem tão pouco existe um tempo exato
determinado de luto de gestação ou de
renascimento desse novo eu que se
apresenta depois de cada fundo
lá naquele enterro eu morri também os
meus amigos que estavam achando comigo
me pediram uma única coisa clara por
favor
independente do que aconteça não
desconta a sua raiva no Marcelo
Oi Marcela Marcela disse
Oi Marcela era a namorada
namorado eu não sabia que existia mas a
minha existência já tinha atrapalhado o
relacionamento deles depois de mais de
10 horas alucinando naquele velório eu
vi que a Marcela tava segurando uma as
flores brancas na mão e eu pensei Nossa
mas eu tô aqui acabada fedida destruída
de onde Essas flores brancas vieram como
que alguém em um momento com esse
consegue pensar encontrar flores dentes
é claramente eu guardei os seus
pensamentos do processo da mim e entrei
na fila para fazer a despedida final
antes que eles guardassem o caixão dele
no couro
a mais que eu passei na frente dela ela
estendeu a mão para mim me deu as cores
verdes
toma eu sei o quanto você é importante
para ele
e olha
E se ela tivesse me espancado
provavelmente teria Google um pouco
menos
o que antes que eu pudesse me escurecer
contra aquela morte prematura eu tiro
essa clareza de que toda dor que me
conduzir até ali era a única forma que
eu poderia ter aprendido o que significa
nobreza e gentileza na praia eu me
arriscaria dizer que dentro do nosso
mundo interno todo mundo tem essas
emoções e Pensamentos que se ditos em
voz alta nos deixaram com pouco de
vergonha
e saber reconhecer em dialogar esses
sentimentos e pensamentos é o primeiro
passo para decidir se a gente quer eles
vivos ou não E é claro que lugar Óbvio
uma história como essa seria o hangar
tudo chegaram sabático explorar as
nossas grandes paixões e aproveitar o
tempo que nos resta o lugar não houve
dessa mesma história que a Marcela me
ensinou é sobre ser absolutamente Gentil
mesmo nas piores condições é um convite
para cuidar de cada palavra que
colocamos no mundo porque a gente sempre
pode falar o que a gente acredita mas
sem precisar ofender o desmerecendo e ao
mesmo tempo é sobre
radicalmente transparente trocar a
justificativas por um pouco pedido de
desculpa
economizar nos elogios declarações e
agradecimento Olá tudo isso é válido não
só para os nossos amigos colegas de
trabalho ou parentes mas sinta todo
mundo que cruzar o nosso caminho
principalmente em um dia difícil
a
ideia de se transformar em vídeo não é
nova Afinal seja você um empreendedor
uma mãe de primeira viagem Ou aquele que
foi recentemente promovido no trabalho
você já sabe o que te trouxe até aqui
provavelmente não vai te servir daqui
para frente
e esse mundo que nos pede tanta
autoridade consistência é preciso muita
serenidade para depois de alguns anos de
carreira poder dizer eu não sei mas eu
sigo disponível tanto para aprender
quanto para riscar
e talvez a boa notícia dessa conversa é
que a gente não precisa perder alguém
ouvir a morte de maneira tão escancarada
Para Morrer que nós morremos sempre um
relacionamento termina é sempre que uma
demissão acontece nós morremos sempre
que falhamos na frente de alguém muito
importante e curiosamente nós também
morremos assim que realizamos algo que
desejamos por muito tempo outras fazer a
tremer de medo
a minha morte em Fi é um prazo concreto
que deve nos trazer uma urgência na vida
mas também devemos permitir caminhar com
um pouco mais de calma calma para
aceitar o ritmo de cada ciclo da Vivo
para aceitar o tempo de construção de um
projeto e também para fazer boas
escolhas trocando um convite tentador
por uma boa noite de descanso
e para tempo a morte é uma forma sem
igual para decidir a vida é a chance de
parar diante de um desafio
respirar frango e se perguntar se esse
fosse o meu último momento vida como é
que eu gostaria de ser lembrada
e inclusive o estudo muito famoso
publicada no livro A ciência da
Felicidade
a uma teoria de que sessenta por cento
daquele tudo aquilo que nos permite
encontrar a realização e bem-estar está
fora de nosso controle cerca de
cinquenta por cento fica coloca genética
e 10 por cento com todos os
acontecimentos que responderam
é mas com esses quarenta por cento de
resto nós podemos e devemos contar com a
nossa
intencionalidade diante da vida A grande
questão é uma versão um tem que morrer
para que eu possa viver de verdade
e talvez a minha versão que tem medo de
arriscar
talvez aquela que não diz como se sente
talvez a minha versão mal humorada que
acha que tem todas as respostas ou
talvez todas
a aceitar a morte de Quem fuma é um
lugar de coragem mas não era Oi Cal
metafísica é uma coragem cotidiana uma
coragem do dia a dia
É eu sei que esse meu ex-namorado
estivesse vivo Ele ficaria orgulhoso em
saber que aquela menina que achava que a
sua força era sua agressividade morreu
ficaria feliz em saber que já são quase
7 anos desde que eu conheci o me casei o
melhor e mais doce homem desse mundo e
que hoje essa menina está profundamente
comprometida em ser gente sempre que
possível porque afinal é sempre possível
na escola da vida eu aprendi que são os
nossos privilégios nos separam mas a
gente ainda tem a chance de se conectar
intencionalmente e apaixonadamente em
vida com tudo aquilo que nos faz humanos
e exatamente iguais aos nossos medos as
nossas expectativas e a certeza de que
em algum momento inevitavelmente nós
vamos lá
e por vocês eu quero ser lembrada não
como alguém que gosta da Morte mas como
a gente vive muito bem sempre atenta a
ela ia ser vendo aqui é mais uma
despedida dessa minha versão vaidosa que
acredita que tem algo realmente valioso
para compartilhar e eu ainda não sei o
tempo de luto e nem o que virá tá
simples dessa Lara que acaba de morrer
por aqui muito obrigado a
[Música]